voici la province à mathieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux que personne ne souffre je me
pose dans la grèce d'abord à mathieu
leur montre comment s'appelle-t-elle mes
victoires pour deux matrices
non-victoire programmatrice déjà c'est
victoria victoria et la remercie
victoria pour la victoire alors
merci d'être là n'y a rien de rien ça va
tu es bien chez nous oui c'est super
c'est vrai naturel tu allais pas dire
non je veux pas dire non mais bon tu es
heureuse on va bien très heureuse alors
mettons rien
est ce que il ya des gens qui sont sympa
avec tout autour de la table
oui tout le monde est pratiquement
s'allier victoria je vais te reposer
l'action
est ce que tu admires tout le monde
autour de la table j'aime bien tout le
monde à levi sabia temps des fois
que tu aimes le plus la personne que
j'aime le plus saint raymond d'accord
normal comme moi mais guillaume aussi
j'ai rarement
des fois benjamin des fois j'ai demandé
pourquoi donc famille
et mathieu ça voilà ça dépend son humeur
alors il peut être au loup un peu
d'accord donc c'est bien mathieu dender
parler c'est bon alors quel est votre
poste donc je suis programmatrice
artistique alors justement remarqué ça
consiste en quoi à se tenir au courant
de l'actualité des artistes et du coup
de les inviter en fonction de leur promo
mais on n'a jamais d'invités dont
commandes
[Rires]
actualité politique ouais donc il n'y a
pas trop la place pour un artiste mais
aurait déjà pour la saison prochaine
important parce qu'il ya des gens qui
vont
revenant sur les souliers
écoute un gros bisou
on continue
avec une deuxième personne vous savez
voilà il faudrait mettre à l'honneur des
personnes voilà qui qui travaillent avec
nous vous savez je voulais dire
du travail invisible
regardez deuxième personne
[Musique]
l'emploi pas de cette personne
léa exactement comment ça marche et riz
provient micro ça va être les à
jallet on se connaît depuis très
longtemps en effet le calme toi ça va
tu as quel âge maintenant toi j'ai 23
ans et depuis 10 ans à la comète sérieux
ça fait dix ans que je connais depuis
que j'ai 15 ans way exactement parce
qu'elles venaient tu venais me voir à
europe 1 1 et c'est extra c'est fou hein
ah ouais ouais c'est mon rêve t ton rêve
de travailler dans la télé ouais
complètement tord aux âges de dos
complètement les chroniqueurs ce n'était
pas trop dur de les tenir parce que tu
as un petit peu au bout des gants dit
que c'est ça c'est la nounou des
chroniqueurs c'est donc elle voilà qui
vous qui vous dit les sujets qu'il va y
avoir ni vous dit si vous qui vous elle
vous dit si vous êtes vous êtes là ou
pas le soir c'est elle qui vous dit si
vous n'avez pas besoin de venir
est celle qui vous dit qu'il ya des
projections pour aller brahim et que
c'était c'est ça lequel on peut sympa
ils sont tous très gentils et ma prison
leurs petits caractères et le plus bas
jamais il est très beau conte ouais
ouais ouais d'accord et le rôle ou
guillaume y travaillent à 17h30
en faux contre ces accusations avec part
et à part ça je prépare par la mission
il est investi mais tu as ça sont
inquiétés parce que ça sera juste et
très noir
mais je pense qu'il va démarrer beaucoup
plus tôt les prochains jours matthieu
delormeau ça se passe bien ça se passe
très bien c'est vrai ouais vraiment
ouais non vraiment il est adorable mais
kenny savard se voyait pas trop tard non
pas qu'elle a des petites mains il est
mignon à waimes à quelle heure à dix
le max 14 heures max kat onoma
exactement donc après juste après le jt
elle sera là
c'est important mais qui crache le plus
sur ses petits camarades benjamin
[Rires]
stora pharma castaldi est un monstre
c'est la meilleure mais c'est fou ça
mais surtout surgit
cible
celui qui vous pose le plus de problème
c'est benjamin ouais
on applaudit clairvaux
allez on enchaîne maintenant avec à une
autre personne travaille avec nous je le
rappelle c'est la journée
l'international travail invisible et à
plein de gens qui travaillent vous ne
savez pas ce qu'il ya à faire sa lessive
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah écoutez
bakiri ça va très bien comment tu alors
comment il s'appelle nicole qu'est ce
qui fait un ace qui fait ses savates sam
est ce que vous vous demandiez tuer un
monstre quoi j'ai même pas répondre ce
que ça
tu sais pas d'humanité en moi nico est
ce qui fait qu je fais quoi moi je sais
quoi alors mancha a plein de choses
et plus souvent même plus
tous les cm2 tpn on sait exactement
community manager mais c'est sa vie qu
on la connaît également les talons
niçois
avoir bien entendu on vient de nice mon
chéri qui se fait le plus défoncé sur
les réseaux à part moi bien entendu
match
non vraiment je trouve beaucoup de vue
en afrique ou de vue mais c'est un drame
c'est gilles verdez c'est un drame c'est
dramatique
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui laissent
des messages pour daniel mouret et pour
essayer de faire une histoire avec et je
croule sous les messages
étaient en fait quoi alors je la
soutiens
nico
bien sûr vu
nico qui qu'est ce qui te fait le plus
chier à part moi bien entendu mais moi
je le fais graphe ci il appelle la
chaleur ça ça va pas ça va pas savoir
s'ils n'ont jamais ça va sûrement son
nom j'appelle les en fait léa et après
du coup les hommes passent le message
c'était comme un temps où travaillent
ensemble maintenant quatre ans 82
rencontres à ses fans s'étaient pas
croisés d'un ascenseur
est bien avec vous moi pas du débat très
bientôt dispo pour nic offer
alors attention c'est la personne qui va
arriver c'est ça je vous le dis c'est
une personne qui vient d'arriver dans la
boîte forcément il est compliqué de
trouver son poste sur
le premier qui trouve son poste gagnant
un week-end de stade et tente un
week-end spa détente je vous jure que
c'est vrai quel est son poste attention
de l ariège où est le manque d'un vrai
nom de mou le poste sachez qu'elle est
ex miss sénégal
quoique c'est vrai ce n'est pas une
balle elle s'appelle nafi
applaudissements points
ex miss senegaal est trop belle
s'il vous plaît qui vient d'arriver au
seinde h 2 o d'ailleurs on ne sait
jamais rencontré c'est vrai qu'on s'est
jamais vu c'est la première fois qu'on
se voit sur le plateau nafi vient
d'arriver par des biens dans le micro
nafissa fait que ça fait quand même
temps que vous êtes dans la boîte à fric
et un mois et demi un mois et demi
qu'elle est arrivé à faire mal mais vous
avez fait et tu ne l'as jamais vu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que je vais au bureau
ça par mois et demi qu'elle a un
phénomène
rattachés
j'espère que ça ne pouvait pas par match
de la revanche non mais moi mais parce
que moi c'est quand même je suis comme
le président de
signer votre contrat je pense
est le
jeu le jeu est très compliqué parce
qu'elle est là depuis un mois et soit
les eaux dans vos bureaux pour la voir
comment voulez qu'on la connaît
pas vraiment été mis sénégal oui
c'était en 2001 alors vous avez été
michel gala cas demandez pas la chose
oui mais elle est tellement belle
ah oui mais sympathique
h2o oui et d'ailleurs vous dit pas
bonjour comme passer de froid
[Applaudissements]
m
alors pas étonnant non
nafie ali nafie ne soyez pas vexer je ne
dis bonjour à percer
les sites et biens alors ma fille avait
alors déjà merci d'avoir intégré la
boîte merci à venir on ne dit pas ce que
vous faites est ce que vous êtes heureux
chez nous déjà plus un moyen est ce que
ça se passe bien très bien ça va les
gens sont sympas gens sont super sympas
c'est vrai qu'elle est votre quel est
votre chef qui est votre chef at
sénateur-maire de sébastien barbe ont
exactement les directeurs financiers
alors je me
répondez quoi alors elle travaille au
service comptabilité clash 2 occupe de
tout ce qui était dit nous paye les
vacances et tout ça et contrats non
c'est ça c'est ça dans le cas dans
sportweek annonce pas là non non non ils
perdaient alors la rigueur le sourire
vous êtes contrôleuse de gestion nobody
tout ça du tout pas du tout kelly
secrétaire pascal a dit qu'elle voit
mathieu passé à leur secteur il passe
devant elle c'est non on voit matures
sinon voix auront beau passer aussi
peut-être ailleurs et le vois travailler
sur une émission précise ou est-ce que
c'est plutôt l'organisation générale
organisée hassen el mechri
constatant le responsable du pôle
imprimantes
[Rires]
juridique
on n'était pas loin de ta leur laissez
passer alors dites-moi sur l'imprimante
ou sur une semaine mais non c'est moi
non non alors
alors alors des choses que vous même
vous savez pas donc
regarder votre langage des gens il sait
pas qui c'est
car tout cas je suis très content de ma
vie c'est moi qui est vrai chez le oui
si vous dépendez du directeur financier
oui rémois raison malgré un rapport avec
la compta même allez quoi mais j'aimais
l'expert table à l écoute pas
la goutte
vingt deux en amoureux une affichette
comptable bachelot vous savez que donc
vous gagnez un week end sur la piste ho
non non non ça va faire du bien
[Applaudissements]
je vais le dire et je
n'ai pas dit ça vous faire du bien avec
mes sauvegardes du bien des mois
merci et bravo
on n'est pas
dernière personne qui travaille chez h2o
je vous l'avez forcément vu vous avez
forcément vu vous l'avez forcément
croisés elle est dans la prod de
l'émission ah oui oui oui oui
oui
à la rive
c
on est près de moi comment ça va alors
je vous ai jamais vu billets comme ça
pour dire que je ne vois pas beaucoup
c'est quand on la verra fois que
j'arrive avec jeunes au bureau pour voir
si vous travaillez dans les bureaux le
mois dernier mais non le mois dernier de
quelle année
honnêtement on a compté était venu six
fois depuis le début janvier quand vous
avez vraiment compter aïe ça veut dire
qu'ils s'amusent à faire ça a coûté ma
c'est sympa est-ce que vous avez une
idée sur cette jeune fille
mélanie ça va
ça dans la vie oui dans la vie où j'ai
vous chez nous
les charmants tel et tel accueil
non non et même site à l'amour parce
qu'elle sait guillem machine à café chez
vous il faut payer mais que je déteste
payer donc le temps qui va du coup j'ai
dit sarov coma et est mort et la petite
dose est que la maman de nos clients un
scénario pas les faux billets le plus en
plus je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
j'aime et qui filait alors pu s'habiller
tout ça je n'ai pas beaucoup d'illusions
en fait vous établi pour l époque les
germains d'habitude quand même
[Rires]
moi c'est la mode carcassonne m quel
accueil quand même allons allons nuisait
à l'accueil d'âge de l'eau juste à
l'accueil le dock est ce qu ici parce
que c'est la société production est ce
qu'on n'a pas d'appels entrants qui nous
appellent
les gens qui veulent se parler mais qui
les fans adacore très bien mais si on a
un stade il n'y a pas de dirigeant n'est
pas le mec de chaînes qui nous appellent
un an battue je sais personnes réclament
les chroniqueurs jean
ya plein de gens qui viennent vous voir
les gens qui viennent me voir je suis
pas
parce qu'on est en train d'assister à un
licenciement est
la
seule à d'autres postes c'est votre
assistante alain c'est mon assistant
personnel et oui sahara depuis qu'en
trois mois à fin janvier 20 journées est
ce que ça se passe bien ça va alors
votre principale activité est assistante
à s'alourdir au téléspectateur mettre du
chlore et du perche dans votre pc
le sac de padel rien tout le monde
s'occupe et son paddle c'est vrai c'est
tout elle prépare le jeu s'occupe que de
sacs soient bien préparés y est voilà
les tournois les matchs 3 p 250 p 500
connaît tous
il faut que tu lis calais déjeuner les
machins ce n'est pas mon cas les jouets
jamais déchaîné s'écoule pas devient ya
pas de calais son paddle n'y a pas
d'autres activités à kayar manière
marigarde charnière hier matin c'est
tant pis 2000 et 2001
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si vous avez déjà calé un autre sans
rigoler
j'ai pas compris qui donc payer pour
répondre à des téléphones à l'accueil
alors que personne appelle lé des
respects des rendez vous que vous n'avez
pardon c'est peut-être sa chair est un
autre truc je ne fais jamais de déchets
jamais quoi ça ne m'intéresse pas de
déjeuner que les gens ne sait pas que de
la scène ce qui ne se nourrir mais la
méthodologie
de toi ça il ya un traumatisme créé
quelque chose est fait trop de dégâts
avant sa chambre il a même largement
lentilles sont frappés petit je vais
faire du sport c'est vrai et elle en
fait elle est chargée aussi d'appeler
les différents partenaires pour savoir
qui veut jouer avec moi tel ou tel
tournoi à bata numéro légales n'ont pas
gallan parce que ghailani il faudrait
qu'on en a fait une exhibition mais la
numéro de tous les accords en fait je me
trouvais en fait c'est l'industrie if
voilà il donc voilà drac et ça je peux
vous dire que ça a du boulot
oui mais tu étais dans le padd à la
vente je connais
en héros et redouane en terre et était
dans le
nez ça a été du milieu
des gens bah oui bien sûr mais j'ai pas
le choix c'est vrai voilà bah merci
voilà vous avez
[Applaudissements]